foreign
[Music]
I'm going to come to you first Mo before
you came out you introduced the film and
you said funny shit can be serious and
serious shit can be funny and we had a
lot of laughs in here over a lot of uh
heavy stuff how did you do it
um explain that quote
and then tell us what made you think
about this film when thinking about that
quote
that's a great question thank you and
thank you all again for being here on
this Windy Wednesday in L.A
this is amazing it's beautiful I'm just
taking it in y'all gonna have to forgive
me for just taking it in I don't take
anything for granted My Beautiful cast
and supporters up here
um in terms of the question
I wanted to make a film that touched on
and was able to articulate a lot of
private conversations I had in my mind
with people close to me and things that
were happening in the world but I didn't
want to be fucking boring I didn't want
it to be didactic I didn't want to be
one-dimensional so and thinking about
that and thinking about my own life how
often times really bad things happen and
when I think back and reflect it was
kind of absurd and wasn't that big of a
deal it was crazy and like it's all
absurd a lot of it is really crazy so I
felt like this story in order to touch
on these topics and to do it in a way
that could hopefully be fresh and unique
for an audience bringing levity and
introducing that absurdity will give us
an opportunity to maybe pick up some
things that are thought provoking but
also have a good time in the process
cool
um who did you have in mind
um when you created this film like who
would be your perfect audience member
for before
as an audience who would be your perfect
audience member everybody that's here
tonight
[Laughter]
Give It Up
no seriously it's the people that show
up on a Wednesday to see a film like
this is the people that like to think
it's the people that like to feel it's
the people that appreciate art that are
okay with questioning thank you
all right like Mo really is up there I
know right
no but it's really everybody that's like
appreciative of Art and people pushing
boundaries and having uncomfortable
conversations that's the audience okay
um I'll punch out to the cast as I go uh
down here
um how did each of you get involved in
the film other than an audition uh and
and why was it important for you to be
involved into this uh and I'll start
with you
my man for a little minute we did a
movie together and uh like I could just
tell just from that experience that it
was somebody I always wanted that it was
it was somebody that I wanted to be
around
um so when he told me about the audition
it really was a no-brainer and then it
just helps that the script that he wrote
was just absolutely incredible
in an audition yeah that was that's kind
of how I got into it cool uh Lex
well I was around for when it was a
short film and watched him go through
that process
and uh also was an advocate for him to
create the feature and I mean we're
we're married and right
[Laughter]
of yours right so give it up for my muse
foreign
but it was it's very personal for me to
be a part of I'm lucky enough to be a
part of it
um I actually sat back and and didn't
expect to even get the chance and the
opportunity to be in and I would just
kind of just just champing him to write
it and to to take a risk and to just
just let life go a little bit and
support whatever we needed to do for him
to get the pages done and we did a table
read at our house and on our dining room
table and invited some friends and it
just it came to life before our eyes and
so to be able again lucky enough to play
Candy is an understatement for me really
it's personal I just want to see him win
really cool if he wins you win too right
said when he wins you win as well right
absolutely yes yeah that's all right
Shamir
mine's not that romantic by the way yes
it is okay it is I love you remember
when we first met
um yeah I meant more many moons ago
actually on my first American project
I'm Canadian and uh we got to act
opposite each other and fast forward a
few years later I get this email saying
that moment crazed directing you know
Hollywood's about who you know I'm like
I'm gonna get a straight offer I know
more McRae you know what I'm saying I'm
gonna walk through and get this job know
I had to audition
and so I auditioned back home in Toronto
and you know I made this wacky weird
self tape anyone who knows me I really
pushed the envelope and you know
thankfully Moe saw the art in there that
made me work for it and uh and I showed
up willingly and happily and just being
able to do the the work and you know mo
called me in the car I was driving
behind a Toronto street car saying I was
this guy and he wanted to do this with
me and work opposite some incredible
artist and
um you know starring in this film
alongside these folks has been
incredible you know I look up to all of
them you know I'm a fan first and uh I
was just you know ecstatic to be able to
be a part of this Avenger team of folks
so that's it I'm just the Canadian in
this film
welcome
and to the EPS uh David
um when you guys and any right
any when you guys took a look at this
project
um what made you want a champion and
jump on it
uh well for me personally uh similarly
I've known Mo for a long time we uh did
a film called The Butler together and we
became um thank you
um we we became a fast friends and I
remember saying to Mo we were doing a
scene together and you know every time
every now and again you work with
someone you go whoa that's that is
genuine Talent
um and it was a force it is a force with
him and and so when we started talking
and he uh talked about directing and
then showed me this short there's a
short version of this film that was all
in one take how many minutes was it it
was a it was like 16. 16 minute one take
you know and it was just a
mind-blowingly well executed short film
and um you know I've been a beneficiary
of advocacy you know I think as an
artist as an actor you don't really know
how good you are unless people tell you
um and that's unfortunate
um but it's it's the reality and I say I
only say unfortunate because you you are
reliant on those people and if they
don't exist then you sometimes that
Talent can die on the vine and I've been
someone who's been a beneficiary of
people advocating for me so in a friend
in someone I deeply love and someone who
I truly think is talented my thing was I
just want Mo to be known for the artist
that he is and so you know I just came
on to be able to do anything and
everything I could to to see him fly
cool
thank you
so
here we are
MO is more like a brother than he is a
friend
we've had some
really incredible moments along the way
this film has people spoke about started
as a short
and I've seen a few shorts that Moe
directed prior to that and
Moe is a serious cat
like when he sets his sights on
something he's not playing around
he talks about being from South Central
Stakes are high and he was not playing
around with his approach to this film
so he asked me to produce the short I
said of course he asked me to produce
the film I said of course
and then we set out on his life
changing Journey
Moe talked about being emotional earlier
if we share what we went through on this
film
being shut down halfway through
by covid
in the middle of the shoot covet is
happening
the world is changing
some of the subject matters in this film
are
reflect what was happening in the world
the financing fell out of the movie two
days before we started shooting
we then
rallied together solved that problem
and I'm glossing over quite a bit
of really personal things Spike talked
about putting up his own money for his
first film all of that happened
Mo took out all of the money in his bank
account
until we got the rest of the money
and so there were moments where we
literally had to hold each other up
during this process physically
two black men shooting a film
about pretty unconventional
uh themes
thank you
and and the process of making a film is
like going into battle
you kiss your family you tell them I'll
see you in like three months
17 days in our case yeah and and then
you go to work
right
and it is all encompassing
these beautiful actors which this
process was very much like a play
I mean we sent the actors through
multiple auditions with multiple
chemistry reads and
Shamir was very uh you know
humble and talking about his self tape
it's the best self tape I've ever seen
and
Elan and Cleo
the winner you guys saw at the beginning
of the film which was adopted from the
short was like 11 12 minutes in the
future
longer it literally brought us to tears
when we got that tape that you saw
we had auditioned it so many times went
through it and it is the film that is
written the film that is shot in the
film that is edited but the on the day
watching these beautiful actors execute
the script and bring their Spirits was
a lot
that being said I would just give an eye
to you for anybody to pull together a
lot of filmmakers in the room anyone in
here knows putting a film together from
the beginning actually writing it and
seeing it through to the end when you
lose financing and things like that but
being able to stick it through with
friends and put up your own money
for
um deserves accolades so thank you for a
wonderful job all of you
um when the film opened
um it was crazy looking at this husband
and wife
who had tons of means it looks like
um and I believe his name is James right
and uh he has this wonderful job where
he's an attorney and he's making all
kinds of money and he's working with all
of these white men who's looking at him
as you know this young black man is
coming in here and he's making money for
us and of course he wants to protect
that job and so when he's at home and
his blue silk road and he's laid up and
they turn on the news and it's a police
shooting
uh police brutality once again and it's
a repeated thing and you have two people
in a household
who sees things a little bit differently
and he wants to also keep the peace in
his house
um
it dinged to me that this thing is all
about conversations and conflict
and not necessarily about centered
around police brutality but it's about
having conversations or difficult
conversations with people that sometimes
don't see eye to eye what made you hone
in on the conversations because
everybody in the film seems to see
something a little bit different when
they could be looking at the same thing
yeah I think that's a really used to
assessment that's very much what the
driving force was just the conversations
the conversations I was having the
conversations in the news on Twitter and
all these Facebook arguments and all
these different things we have we all
look at the same moment and it's like a
prism and we all see something different
while looking at the same thing so I
just feel like that was a great
opportunity to have a very objective
look into those varying points of views
and realize that everybody's a little
bit wrong most of the time and nobody's
all the way right right and if the
things that we're all focused on kind of
close to the title ends up being a lot
of nothing all these divisive things
that we focus on ends up amounting to a
lot of nothing
this so I'll ask this of the actors and
any one of you can take this
um as you prepared as an actor for the
character you were
choosing to live in
did you
um did you have to make certain choices
as an actor where you had to set your
own personal feelings aside
as a person to say okay I know I would
never do this but I actually have to
live in this or are there some things
that you would disagree with with your
character
um
[Laughter]
well um it is always going to be that
it's always going to be that I think
that's the the Great Adventure about
acting is sort of you have to be
somebody that is completely
compassionate to what your character
goes through right and with James yeah
there's a lot of things that I I would
do do completely differently I think
um the big thing for him is he's just so
afraid of everything I mean he has this
public Persona that just persists in
everything that he does you know he has
a Persona when it comes to his
relationship with his brother he has a
Persona when it comes to work he has
everything that he does is always
um you know there's no
he's fearful you know he's looking for
safety so that's something I related to
um and I that I was able to find sort of
like a
you know that complimented what I was
working with but
yeah
when you think about uh your character
you played
um are you naturally a jokester like
that or always find the funny and the
randomness situations sometimes you just
gave a simple look and everybody just
like fell out laughing I thought it was
it was amazing amazing job thank you
very much I appreciate it I'm very
serious in my everyday life to be honest
why are you laughing
uh no I just think my main thing When
approaching a role is you know funniest
money Charming is disarming you know and
the Aesthetics of Jamal you know when he
walks into his space
a lot of things come to mind and so I
wanted to
do my best to juxtapose that
where we hear that black men are very
aggressive
and I say that's passion right and Jamal
is passionate about his cause and you
know with passion comes joy and I think
there's joy in Jamal and why you know
there's levity in those things and kudos
to my filmmaker the captain of the ship
who allowed me to you know play Within
the margins and fighting those pops you
know the subject matter you know they're
talking about some some deep stuff you
know we're laughing and whatnot but a
kid died someone's kidnapped and they're
about to go to jail you know somebody
catches you know catches them so it's
important for me to to be able to you
know in the work you know try to find
the levity and all of that but still
keeping it grounded
um you never play the funny right it's
just the circumstance so every time
y'all are laughing Jamal is serious but
you know you all found that you know
people found that interesting and funny
I think that's the beauty about all the
performances here is that you know
even Jamal you know is who you know
Jamal and and uh you know online and and
you know what he's doing is hilarious
across the board but he's you know as
conviction and he's decisive you know
and he has his North Star and he wants
to chase it you know but um but yeah you
know it comes from the page I told this
to Moe and you know he wrote it you know
and all we did as actors is just added
our sauce so yeah cool Lex
um you were able to highlight
something when it comes to food being a
vegan
um
I thought it was interesting because
that made it made the movie not just
about police brutality but a lot of
conversations we have and getting
arguments about
um something simple as food and she's
like well it's a free-range chicken
and I think you wrote well it's not free
if it's I guess born
be slaughtered or something like that I
was like man that was that was cold oh
but
talk about your character um because I
found her really interesting um and
engaging
um but the most laid back and grounded
it seemed to me
as well
um
she's
you did a table read of it on the page
you could easily read all of those
things as tropes something that comes
with Hollywood or you know
um and mo pushed for it to be grounded
and pushed for it to remind us of that
that a round-away girl that we all know
um who was just a little bit she she
believes she's elevated in her mindset
you know she's above certain things of
her community
um
but not to put anyone down but just to
Enlighten our our community really and
um I think it's just a lot of it's
relatable because I when I met Mo I also
was a vegan so I was like certain so
there's a lot of stuff in there that is
is very similar to myself at the same
time um just in general for me and I
think should see
strategically so into the writing
there's something in all of us in each
of these characters that is extremely
relatable even officer Brian
and a huge part of going into making
something that seemingly tropey feel
grounded is because we all are
stretching to find ourselves in all of
these voices and Moe's writing is
exceptional to be able to break down the
psyche of so many minds of different
Americans
every voice in this room every mind in
his room something up there was said
that you were probably thinking and
something up there was said that
probably made you uncomfortable but the
point of it was us to figure out why
yes
don't look at me like that
um mentioned something it was
it was at the top of the show when they
learned of the police shooting the young
child
and they were trying to figure out what
to do
and they built it up and it was like
let's make a post
um how many of you made posts before
are we not keeping it real in here oh I
thought this was a real space
um
talk about that in this age of like
social media a lot of times people make
it out in March somebody else may donate
um and somebody might sit at home
and write a post and sometimes that can
seem really ineffective
um tell us your thoughts about it and
why that was so specific so quickly the
thought process on that for me and kind
of like one of the things that actually
ends up being like the Bastion of the
whole film is that we all want to do
something
but what can we actually do ends up
being the thought so the thing that we
have access to I've heard this phrase I
thought was great like armchair activism
and you in your chair you're at home you
fired up you're arguing with your auntie
who's voting for the wrong person on
Facebook and all that stuff is happening
so I was like that's what we all do
that's what we relate to and then I was
like okay now what happens if we take it
one step further and actually do
something with the problem being next
door so the first thing was like okay
let's do what we always do which is
social media and then the question the
thesis statement is what happens if we
do the next thing and then discover
we're actually ill-equipped
to do anything else and then that felt
like for me a great opportunity for the
dramatic tension the comedy errors and
this whole exploration in this journey
because like what do we do I don't know
but what if we did that well now we see
what happens right
it's
I guess
you end up going to the Absurd um
you kidnap somebody and bring them into
your house and there's all kind of
Errors made
um
after the entire process uh seeing
what's went on in the world I think I
find it interesting that you all made
this movie in the height of the pandemic
uh given the uh access to George Floyd
and everything else that happened in
2020 and before and still going on and
afterwards
um
what now after this film what do you
want people to take away from it
I'm so happy you asked me that because
every time someone asked me what I want
people to take away depending on where I
am in my life or in that day I feel like
it's something different but the one
consistent
is I want people to leave this film and
give themselves permission to feel
whatever they felt
and be okay with that I feel like we're
in a time where we're not feeling like
we're giving the opportunity to be
truthful to how we feel in terms of what
we need what hurts us what makes us
laugh what makes us cry so I wanted to
create something where you have those
moments like the Facebook post and a lot
of people laugh
is some people lean forward like oh yeah
they write a good fucking post
and that's okay both of those things are
okay and hopefully in that thought of
being able to feel whatever you feel and
be comfortable with that then you can
have an honest conversation with
yourself and then on this conversation
with other people in this world that we
inhabit because right now all the
conversations feel fake and it's not
real so I think it's up to the artists
like these wonderful people here that
lent their their
and this is where me because
ah it's just
I I'm speaking about this film and
oftentimes it feels unfair for me to
answer and talk about it so much because
it only exists because of these people
and so many other people whether it was
the money falling out the people uh
giving notes on the script the pas
the grips we were making this move out
my camera I see Aaron Gantt here Aaron
raise your hand bro
operated the camera
for that Warner in the beginning
[Applause]
that's
we did you know it's 20 minutes I don't
know what we shot on an area Alexa
that's a big ass camera
and we did multiple takes after take
after take
and when we got shut down
I never forget all the tearful phone
calls
and I've been in this industry for 20
years and on this movie I saw like I
never seen a grip cry in my whole life
I saw grips cry just saw so many people
give so much and there's something about
that process of whether people like the
movie or not I hope there's a
that
the really motion and heart and care
that went into it is palpable whether
you agree with the choices or not this
is truly a labor of love and a pure
attempt at Art and an offering into the
world I could hopefully do something on
some level even if it's only make you
have one thought
one feeling then we've won with this
film
cool and a wonderful job by the way give
it up
what would you say to other filmmakers
or even to other actors other producers
and anybody can answer this question who
find themselves in that position to
where the finances just fell out of the
bottle
um we lost someone for whatever reason
what do you say to someone to help them
keep going
keep going
that's it honest to God that's it like I
remember I had a very pointy moment with
a friend of mine who's incredibly
successful I was in his backyard
palatial home I was having a rough time
in my life and I was like man shit is
hard this went wrong this was bad and
he's like yeah I've been through stuff
too
and so for all you filmmakers and I list
a bunch of talented people hardly
anybody else chime in but it's going to
be hard it's supposed to be hard you
have to accept that like Jordan is who
he is because of what he did with the
flu
the flu game when I think about Jordans
what makes him special so you got to
embrace the adversity and keep on
playing
okay let me let me add to that come on
McCray go for it Andy Clements well you
said something at the beginning you said
you came from a place where people just
kept telling you what you can't do what
you shouldn't do
and a lot of us
in this path like there's no road map to
becoming a producer or you know
especially if you come from where we
come from
and so
most likely do you want to produce this
movie with me I'm like hell yeah
like let's go do it
but there's no
real nurturing system that
gives you the tools to go out and say
you can do that
so it really is
this connection that you have with your
tribe in this
town and a lot of people in this room
are a part of that tribe
from wives to daughters to friends they
give you that
you know audacity to fucking do it
Moe was talking about his cameraman in
this film
when candy is giving birth I cry almost
every time
it is so beautifully
shot
and directed and mo is on the camera in
that scene
with his wife
delivering this baby and it was real
moments happening
these actors had to stop what they were
doing in the middle of the movie
and just sit in the character
for 10 months
and come back
even more like the world had changed
even more dedicated to the character
even more in pocket
before we shut down
and so when you see the commitment of
artists
it keeps you going
when I see friends out there
on screen killing it it keeps me going
when I see David doing his thing around
the world
in multiple things
in all kinds of arenas
it keeps me going
Shamir is all over the place
doing everything John Wick 4 coming up
and keeps you going
and so
the victory
is
sitting here accomplishing something
that many people said we couldn't do
amen you guys are going to kill a cop at
again
the white cop
audiences are conditioned to see black
people die
in a film
so we have people step to us and say yo
it's great but
think you might have to change the
ending
why well it just makes people feel
uncomfortable exactly
give it up for them y'all
and it looks like we're getting the wind
it up sign so I'll say this uh wonderful
film uh enjoyed watching it and the one
thing I'll take away and I hope everyone
in here takes away it'll be one of
Candy's lines
um and it said an open dialogue requires
an open mind yeah yeah
uh give it up
thank y'all thank you so much thank you
thank you
[Music]